are there tactics you could tell men
that aren't sociopathic but can work to
help them get women there aren't really
very good cheat codes the way to attract
a good girlfriend is actually become a
better man and build the traits that are
attractive if you just allocate a little
bit of time and energy you can actually
get dramatic improvements in many of
these traits get enough sleep eat right
so your blood sugar is not going up and
down all the time do your exercise
meditate be mindful and then there's a
bunch of other traits that matter to
women sense of humor you can work on
that it's a lot of young men are
misallocating their learning times like
getting really good at Call of Duty or
some video game and they could take the
hundreds of hours if they're doing that
and allocate it to stuff that women
actually care about and improve it
dramatically